[Music]
right now as the criminal investigation
into zero experience hunter and his dad
is heating up republican lawmakers
they're now looking for answers on his
foreign business dealings with the
family syndicate they're now demanding
that he turn over communications with
the obama white house now writing in
letters to the white house and national
archives quote hunter biden's
connections throughout the russia
russian sphere
of influence have now become especially
relevant in the fast-moving and
developing russian war in ukraine and
today former federal prosecutor brett
tolman claimed that if the investigation
revolved around anyone other than hunter
biden they would have already been
indicted now but hunter's corrupt
business transactions extend far beyond
russia as we have chronicled on this
show and made well
apparently made over a million dollars
sitting on the board of barista well
over a million him and his company took
in and he took money from let's see a
kazakhstan oligarch for a brand new
sports car
and a russian oligarch the former first
lady of moscow that's three and a half
million and a hundred thousand dollar
shopping spree with with a chinese
national and then of course millions and
millions of dollars in other business
deals with
connections to the ccp
uh and also chinese intelligence and the
1.5 billion deal with the bank of china
now despite mountains of evidence to the
contrary biden lied about all of this
repeatedly claiming again and again and
again that he and his son never at one
point ever discussed his foreign
business dealings and he never profited
from his business dealings in china take
a look
my son has not made money
in terms of this thing about uh what are
you talking about china i have not had
the only guy made money from china is
this guy he's the only one nobody else
has made money from china
joey was lying and when pushed on the
issue during yesterday's white house
briefings well the communications
director kate bettingfield doubled down
on biden's lies wow what a shocker take
a look
we absolutely stand by the president's
comment and i would point you to uh the
reporting on this which referenced
statements that we made at the time
that we gave to the washington post who
worked on this story uh and but as you
know i don't speak for hunter biden so
there's not more i can say on that it
was reaction the man that turned
hunter's laptop over to the fbi law
enforcement john paul mack isaac is with
us and fox news contributor jason chavis
um
john paul
you
you'd put everything on the line here
you're given a laptop you see
information in the course of recovering
what's on the laptop that is concerning
to you
in terms of the legal aspect of it
all of a sudden
the laptops never picked up you hand it
over to the fbi
and your life's been nothing but a
living hell as a result of it tell us
what your life has been like since you
did this
well once
once the story was out and my name was
leaked to the public it uh
it's been a matter of at first running
and hiding
uh and now it's trying to just rebuild
my life and and do it in a manner that's
not restricted by public opinion of me
being involved in a russian
disinformation campaign
yeah and but why did you have to close
down your shop this was your business
well initially the media did a good job
of blocking the story so customers were
still coming in but they didn't
understand the police presence or why
there was
feces and rotten vegetables thrown at
the shop so eventually it got out and
people stopped coming in
for service people started coming in
without computers and i can only imagine
that they were there to do me harm so
by the end of november by by the end of
october i had made a decision and by
november 2nd i closed the shop
you know there's now miranda devine's
book the laptop from hell
what specifically alarmed you that there
might be
something illegal on that laptop
specifically i don't know that you've
ever answered that question
well i saw a lot of things that were
embarrassing that somebody would
definitely not want to make to the
tabloids
because i saw a lot of financial records
that uh showed a lot of uh foreign money
and a lot of money like a lot of money
and then there was uh some other
documents that i thought were kind of
strange uh blue star strategies uh
sending
white house briefings about ukraine and
the vice president's travel schedule to
a private ukrainian citizen and the
national security
ramifications alone
were disturbing and i felt that this was
definitely something that had to be
taken to the fbi
and you also saw illegal activity the
you for example the picture of
hunter biden with the crack pipe
that's illegal activity
uh
pictures of a sexual nature um were you
concerned about the age of the people in
the pictures
no i did i didn't really focus my
attention on what was
salacious on the laptop my bigger
concern was the security of the nation
the the criminality that had potentially
taken place and that could happen again
if not investigated properly
you know jason it was authenticated
because apparently hunter's lawyers came
back months later asking for hunter's
laptop back you would think that would
have been
the defining moment where the media
would have realized this thing is real
what's your take on all of it
well first of all the john i hope he
understands there are millions of people
who are appreciative and i hope he's
buoyed up despite all the the stuff that
he's taken in his personal life there
are those of us that care about law and
order and justice and it takes people
like you stepping up so thank you for
doing that um i i wish the the criminal
justice system though in this country
would take it seriously it's one thing
we we know that the washington post and
the new york times and msnbc we know
they're in the pocket of the democrats
and that they'll do anything and
everything uh to to get their people
elected
but we don't have the u.s attorneys
moving the way they should where's the
irs in a lot of this where's the foreign
intelligence services how come adam
schiff still has a security clearance
how come eric swalwell still has a
security clearance and sits on the intel
committee that i could go on and on and
on we didn't even mention romanian the
hundred thousand dollars that went into
joe biden's grandkids from the former
director of the fbi louis free uh that
they're all
in mexico and providing access there's
so much but john was right he saw
something was wrong he provided it to
the authorities but the authorities are
letting him down and letting the rest of
the country down by not pursuing and
putting this guy in handcuffs
yeah i mean it really is uh unbelievable
john paul mack isaac i want to echo
jason's comments um i'm so sorry that
this has impacted your life regularly
it's amazing that
democrats supposedly supposedly praise
whistleblowers even hearsay
non-whistleblower whistleblowers
and yet
you did the right thing and you've been
harmed because of it um thank you for
all you you've done for your country and
we wish you the very best and thanks for
being with us tonight jason thank you